notice you've got total freedom of
choice when it comes to ending a
pregnancy but if you have concerns about
starting one about fertility
no interesting well patsy's italian
restaurant was one of the most iconic
restaurants in new york but since
coronavirus new york's leaders have done
everything they can
to destroy it and businesses like it and
sadly they're succeeding
patsy's italian is now leaving new york
and moving to new jersey
sales cognello is the owner of patsy's
he joins us
tonight to explain what happened sally i
appreciate you're coming on what a sad
story
um you've been in new york i think how
long has your restaurant been in new
york actually
seven uh seven 77 years and and just to
be clear we're not uh we're not going to
be leaving permanently i plan on coming
back and reopening
when the city gets a plan for us right
now and we're doing a pop-up restaurant
in asbury park new jersey
and that's for february march and april
right now it's been going very well
and i love new york and i'm rooting for
new york new york is the epicenter
of education finance the arts
so many different things and you know we
need a plan for new york to come back
you know
my wife likes to use the word
opportunity so we had the opportunity to
go to asbury park new jersey and the way
that came about was
have a friend of mine who lives in um a
town very close by
spring lake new jersey his name is john
fudge and i called him up and i said
what do you know about asbury park a few
people have been saying to me it's it's
a wonderful place it's only 60 miles
from new york city
and my friend john fudge happened to be
a child of that era
he his father had a store in asbury park
and he knew it very well
and he in two and a half months it's
quite miraculous we were able to put
together
a deal with the the manzo family they're
from the real housewives of new jersey
they're doing the food and beverage at
the berkeley hotel in asbury park
and a few words one led to the other and
the uh the
patriarch al manzo has been coming to my
restaurant for
30 40 years and he said i'd love to have
you down here and we opened
just a few weeks ago and i have to tell
you the response has been
overwhelmingly positive everyone wants
us to stay there they think it's a great
thing
and we've been very very busy i always
try and look for solutions
and the solution for new york is we have
to get
opportunity back to new york they need
to get incentives for people to come
back to travel of course
to come and stay at the hotels and if
that my know yeah sorry did you wrap it
up for me your issue is
well my issue is that you know you have
the 1.4 percent
is the spread in in uh you know when
they say in the restaurants and bars
and you have 74 percent living room
spread now you have manhattan which
has consistently been one of the lowest
rates of infection in the entire state
of new york
and it's closed and then you have
upstate new york nassau and suffolk
county and it's a much higher rate of
infection
and it's it's open so i mean what is it
you're not going to get
the virus when you're in in long island
or upstate new york but you will get it
when you're in
in new york city it just didn't make
sense to me 50 percent
it never made it never made sense well
i appreciate you coming on tonight and i
appreciate your restaurant i've gained a
lot of weight there
thank you well
we will be back don't give up on new
york yet good okay
thank you